Film Courage: Gordy we had a question come
in earlier from Twitter, it’s a lady named
Mexie and she’s from Australia I believe
and she says I would love to see interviews
or discussions on developing secondary characters.
So any thoughts on developing secondary characters?
Gordy Hoffman, Founder/Judge of BlueCat Screenplay
Competition: Well your cast size is always
a concern because you have to give each character
enough real estate in your script to create
enough moments (emotional moments) that the
audience can relate to and identify and connect
with and secondary, primary, supporting, if
you choose to have a character that you are
going to develop, you can arc them out in
the same way like what is the beginning, middle
and end of this journey of this character.
I wouldn’t get too concerned with theme
or how they relate or whatever but if you’re
trying to develop any character, you want
to be like well what is there, do you have
enough scenes where the audience can relate
and are they going on an emotional journey,
an interior journey, an external journey (whatever),
the combination of both.
But you build it the same way of any of your
characters.
You want to create enough moments where the
audience can see themselves so it’s plausible,
emotional, high stakes stuff where the audience
can see themselves reflected and they identify
and they sympathize.
So it’s the same things, that’s how I
look at everything.
I don’t get caught up in like formulas as
to where things are suppose to happen in stories.
I think it’s mostly you want to focus on
you know and I don’t think there’s a lot
talked about with character so it’s a very
good question but mostly it’s the screenplay
only has so long.
You only have two to two and a half hours
to go right or something like that (an hour
and a half) and you want to have as many moments
because a relationship is defined by the volume
of moments that we have with the person.
If you have coffee with the person once a
year then if you pass away you have one kind
of emotional response.
If you have coffee with somebody everyday
out of the whole year that’s going to hit
you more.
So in the script if we see that secondary
character or any character and we’re able
to see them different context go through different
things and there is a greater volume of access
to them in different days, different times,
different locations, doing different things
and bouncing through this plot that’s why
cast sizes are small that’s why with CASABLANCA
it’s basically a story about three people.
That’s why Harry Potter’s eight movies
basically around three people (really around
one guy), there’s three people, I mean there’s
other characters but we’re not asked to
connect with a bunch.
When you have something longer like GAME OF
THRONES you’re able to connect with more
people because there’s more real estate
but that’s only because there’s more real
estate and that’s how we find our way in
to the main characters but still there are
a few that garner most of our attention.